[Musique]
la villa savoye en état de siège
pas d'inquiétude il s'agit d'une
exposition de fauteuils de la chaise
caddie à la chaise longue face à face en
passant par le fauteuil à bascule 20
pièces au total issues de la collection
du mobilier national
une exposition baptisée siège moderne
des sièges à la fois des années 60 au
ras du sol très bas qui montre une
nouvelle façon de s'asseoir dans ces
années là où des sièges beaucoup plus
contemporain en fibre de lin en fibre de
carbone qui montre le savoir faire dans
le dans les matériaux composites pour
rappel la villa savoye été construite
par le corbusier pierre jeanneret entre
1928 et 1931 avec une fonction de lieu
de vie pour les époux sabour
l'exposition actuelle s'inscrit dans les
lieux de la ville à savoir de façon à
proposer une forme de dialogue entre
l'architecturé iconiques que représente
la ville à savoir aujourd'hui mais de
rappeler aussi sa fonction d'habitation
sa fonction des usages
à quelques pas de la villa savoye la
maison de fer accueille l'exposition
intitulée le design de métal le lien du
coup avec l'exposition mobilier de
design et le design de métal notamment
ailier bien évidemment aux matériaux de
construction de la maison de faire mais
également à la valorisation des
savoir-faire de l'atelier de création et
de recherche du mobilier national
dix projets conçus en métal par
l'atelier de recherche et de création
fer de lance de la créativité au sein du
mobilier national des oeuvres finaliser
des prototypes ou encore des plans c'est
le cas des lustres conçu pour le
restaurant du loup située à abu dhabi ou
encore de cette console aux courbes
d'acier
on console qui a été conçu par olivier
védrine en inox martelé qui montre un
petit peu tout le savoir-faire de
l'atelier puisque martelé de l'inox
c'est une gageur en termes techniques et
donc une grande prouesse qui montre le
savoir faire des ateliers de l'atelier
de recherche et de création
le mobilier national prend ces assises
de métal à poissy entre la villa savoye
et la maison de fer jusqu'au 26
septembre
[Musique]